The vision and motivation was relatively simple...
...because our founder Adi Dassler once said...
..."I want to have a major innovation for all...
...and for each and every top sports event."
So, it was definitely a huge motivation to say...
..."Okay, what can we do better?"
We wanted to live up authenticity to progression...
...so, really go back to our roots...
...and spice that up with modern elements.
For 48 years, we had to provide the official match ball for the World Cup...
...and in 1970, we started with the Telstar...
...and this Telstar was absolutely unique...
...in its white and black blocking...
...and that's possibly visible on black and white TV.
So, in the end, it really created an iconic element and an iconic moment.